[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
hello welcome to the table my name is
karen miner
thank you so much for joining us on this
rainy evening
uh i don't know about you but i've got
my cup of tea keeping my hands warm
and this is actually a mug that one of
my good friends gave me for my birthday
earlier this year and i thought it was
perfect i wanted to show you if you
could read it it says
where everyone has a seat at the table
so i thought this was perfect for our
service tonight i feel little mr rogers
anyways we're so glad you're here i'm so
glad you're here
welcome um i just have a couple of
announcements tonight
uh as we get things kicked off uh the
first one
i wanted to do a quick shout out to our
book club that's led by sarah johns and
glenda beyron
they picked a fantastic book this month
i just finished it
this morning it's called the vanishing
half it's by
brit bennett it's a number one new york
times bestseller
it's on a bunch of top book lists
of 2020. it is so
so good i got it at the library so
the book club meeting is saturday
february 6th
at 10 a.m it's going to be a virtual
meeting
and there's still time to read the book
so i just wanted to encourage you guys
if you have not yet read this book
and or if you have not yet joined our
book club to connect to there
it's worth your time it's it's good and
excellent excellent book i hope you all
read it um
i believe marissa is going to be posting
information on how you can get the book
and also
how you can get connected with sarah to
get the link
for the meeting again it's a virtual
meeting february 6
10 a.m um and even if even if you don't
get a chance to read the book
tune in to the meeting it's great it's a
great way to get connected with other
people here at the table
which is so important important right
now
in this time of of continuing to do our
services online
um you know hey i
i understand the time is is just the
months and months and months are going
on
uh as you can see we're continuing to do
our services online
and we will continue to do that until
cases in dallas county
start trending below a thousand cases a
day
that's kind of the number we're looking
at
the elder team is continuing to pray and
to talk each time we meet together
just to make sure that we are keeping
the community at large in mind
our medical community just trying to
keep people
as safe and healthy as possible
and you know as i was thinking about
that uh today
and just how man when we started going
online in mid-march
we had no idea that it would turn into
you know going on 10 months now i think
and it's been it's been a trying time
not only from just the standpoint of
getting our services online
trying to keep them as creative and
fresh and connecting as
possible um while staying distanced um
it's been it's been a challenge but i
was thinking just
all of the good stuff that's happened as
a result like just
having people that would otherwise not
step foot
in the doors of the building join us for
church and
we now call them table family
there's been so many good things that
have come from our time online as well
and it reminded me of a scripture in
galatians 6 that says
let us not grow weary in doing good
for at the proper time we will reap a
harvest
if we do not give up and that's so
encouraging
just to remember that god is
orchestrating always
he can take any situation and and use it
for good
and it also reminded me of the brilliant
amanda gorman who gave
[Music]
that just wrote that and delivered that
beautiful poem for the inauguration
this past week called the hill we climb
and
these words she used said uh
that even as we grieved we grew that
even as we hurt
we hoped that even as we tired we tried
and if that's not just a exhortation
for our country also for this community
that we are doing this for good
that's our heart it's our intent
and we want you to feel like you're
you're a part of it
and so that's really our prayer
so i hope you'll continue to keep
joining us online to keep
sharing it with others that could use
some encouragement
maybe some you know lifting of the chins
and the eyes from discouragement or
disappointment or just weariness
that we come together and are reminded
each sunday that
we're not alone and that there's hope
and that we can center on jesus so will
you pray with me
as we enter into worship god
thank you for the encouragement that
your hope
and your peace and your love remains no
matter what's going on around us
god help us strengthen us to not grow
weary in doing good
to not grow weary in just remembering
our values
of staying connected of staying hopeful
of just taking it a day at a time and to
remember that
we are in it together so god i pray that
you would fill each one
of us with your spirit cover us with
your love
and joy and peace and patience
kindness goodness faithfulness
gentleness
and self-control and i pray that tonight
you would speak to our hearts and open
our minds
and god that we would remember that you
are faithful
through the ages and help us to be
present to that god and aware
of that tonight so we center on you and
we thank you
in jesus name amen
a min and amen
you guys i feel like i'm having a
jonathan from queer eye moment and i
just want to be like
yes to amanda gorman yes to galatians 2.
yes to hot tea maggie
got it we are feeling oh and we're so
stripy
oh i just now noticed that for those of
you who don't know
us in person like if we've never met in
person have we ever said
officially we are twins that's a good
point of clarification i feel like that
could be helpful for people like if
they're like
it's so weird to have these two girls
that look the same playing music
together a lot on here
we are twins and we live in the same
house yes
and we're drinking tea if you could see
that
in matching like oh my gosh this is all
unplanned you guys i'm just having this
epiphany but if you could see scott
who's behind the scenes
doing all of our tech right now he has a
cup of tea i i kind of want to put him
on the spot and be like scott would you
show your face and hold up your mug for
us
would you do that i don't know he might
he might be a little oh look at that
we are all twinning in our tennis
tonight
um but anyways
shifting gears brett's probably vaccines
like
what the heck are these girls doing okay
he probably has tea
he does he has tea i think he does have
tea okay
shifting gears though um i just want to
take a moment
to talk about worship lyrics um so
i was planning out the set for this week
me and brett have a meeting every week
where we kind of just go through like
here's what i'm thinking here's what
you're thinking how can we collaborate
um and i was like i really want josh and
joe to do raise a hallelujah it's just
been a long time we haven't gotten to
see their faces for a few weeks and
they always just rock that song and
then i just had this moment where i'm
sitting there thinking of the lyrics of
that song which we've done
for everyone
i mean for forever like we've done that
over and over if you were with us when
we were meeting in person
like that was a regular for us i've
never had this moment
where i had any qualms with that song
but suddenly i think because of our
political climate and our cultural
tensions that are going on
in america right now um i just thought
of like one of the very first
lines of that song is i raise a
hallelujah
in the presence of my enemies and i was
like
oh i don't know if we can do that song
anymore
because i worry that
too often myself included i'll start
with me um i know i grew up with a faith
um that
i i interpreted it this way i don't want
to put it on other people but
where it was me against the world so to
speak
like i am the good i am the holy i am
the righteous child of god i am chosen
blah blah blah blah blah
and all of those other people outside of
my
christian evangelical
um bible believing
bubble were the enemy and of course i
wouldn't treat them like the enemy
like externally like i wanted to love
them and be a witness to them and invite
them in and yada yada
but it easily slips into this like us
against them thing i don't know if any
of you guys experienced this growing up
i hope that this is resonating with some
of you but it's just so easy for me to
go there in my mindset even sometimes
when we're reading scripture
i mean david is writing psalms when he's
literally under physical attack
from people who are coming at him with
weapons
and so when he's writing in the presence
of my enemies there is a literal enemy
standing in front of him
you know like hunting him down here i
am worshiping god and often thinking
of all the people outside of my little
bubble as like
the enemy not intentionally but it just
i go there mentally we do it politically
we do it racially we do it in so many
areas
and i mean shame on me for um adopting a
theology not i shouldn't say shame
i don't believe that god is a god of
shame but i mean it just was convicting
it was one of those moments where i was
like
i need to reframe the narrative i need
to
look at my lyrics that i um so
often find as a comfort to me and say
you know am i viewing this through the
lens of the gospel
where sometimes i am my own
worst enemy it is my own
narrow-mindedness or
selfishness or pride or
whatever and for those of you who may
have heard the story behind
the song that josh and joe are going to
do tonight
um it's a beautiful story and it was
written by a guy
who had these friends whose son was
dying and they were all praying for this
um of this little boy and um so when
he's writing in the presence of my
enemies he's talking about a sickness
um but i think it's just very easy
to walk that line where we're teetering
towards the us versus them
um and man if we could hang on
to some of the message that brett was
talking about last week
um and get rid of some of the divisions
that that create a bit
of you know just like a slight
pedestal that i'm standing on a slight
you know like
me and my ivory tower i don't want to be
that person but i mean i can just
lean that direction and um
man if we could come and approach our
worship times together our community
with a posture of surrender that says
sometimes
i'm the problem sometimes
i am my enemy and
i'm raising a hallelujah trusting
that jesus comes and does a work
in me that saves me from
trusting that he is for me and
for us the world
for the people on this planet that i
believe he has a purpose
and a plan for
regardless of party regardless of race
regardless of
monetary standings or living conditions
if if i could embrace that posture where
i
am one of the i i am the sinner and the
saint
all in the same breath
so anyways i'm gonna step off the
soapbox for a second
i appreciate you bearing with me as i'm
um just kind of verbally processing with
you guys
where this journey has taken me this
week so without further ado scott's
gonna roll
this video that josh and joe did of this
song this week i so appreciate them
doing it and
i hope that we can all um kind of enter
into a posture together
where we're saying jesus come
change us come we trust you
and um we want you to keep doing your
work in us
and we're going to continue to praise
you and worship you in that process
all right
hey everybody welcome to the table we're
glad you're joining us tonight uh
hopefully you can sit back
take a deep breath and sing along with
us
i'm glad you're
raise here hallelujah
in the presence of my enemies
i'll raise a hallelujah
louder than the unbelief
[Music]
is
heaven comes to fight for me
and i'm gonna sing
[Music]
[Applause]
death is defeated the king is
[Music]
[Applause]
with everything inside of me
[Music]
hallelujah
that i will watch the darkness
[Applause]
in the
[Music]
louder and louder you're gonna hear my
praises
[Music]
i'm gonna
is
[Music]
the king is alive
sing a little louder
[Music]
a little
sing a louder louder
[Music]
louder and louder
hallelujah raise a hallelujah
[Music]
i'll raise a hallelujah
so
[Music]
god thank you that you do fight for us
even when we're fighting ourselves
sometimes
we just want to enter into this time
with just a posture of openness
to the work that you do your
transformation
yeah we just surrender to you
you deserve every piece of my heart
every piece of my heart every piece of
my heart
come
[Music]
my
i am trusting that you are
a faithful daughter and
all that you have it
[Music]
break is to me over and over and over
again
i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer you're
drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again over
i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer you're
drawing
[Music]
of me heart lay before you
again come
tear down the walls i've built up
every wall i've built up every wall
[Music]
in my heart
and all that you have it is
over and over and over
again i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer you're
drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before
over and over again
i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer
you're drawing me in as the devs of my
heart lay before you again
[Music]
over again
foreign
[Music]
again
me
no shadow you won't light up
a mountain you won't climb up coming
after me
no wall you won't kick down
i won't tear down coming
after me
[Music]
coming after me yeah
never
[Music]
[Applause]
leaves the night
i don't deserve it still you
give yourself away
never ending reckless
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
again
closer
[Music]
over again
me
god would you make that so real
until we can truly feel it
god until we can truly see the ways that
you are breaking into our lives
and taking away anything that was in the
way
of your love
god we open our hearts and lay them
before you
and ask that you would do what only you
can do god that you would reshape and
reform
and create in us
people who understand what it is to be
fully loved
who are able to give that love away
so we invite you and open ourselves up
and surrender
and thank you for this time together
it's in your sweet
precious holy name that we pray jesus
amen
[Music]
amen thank you ladies
and um man what eve i was just thinking
like
just what a blessing it is um i feel
won't be the one i mean i guess the
religious way would be blessed uh
i feel blessed lucky
fortunate just to have such amazing
people
um as part of this team and
um i know we're such a tiny community
but
just to have maggie and mindy and karen
miner and scott doing tech stuff marissa
martinez is also behind the scenes
posting the links and saying hi to you
all in the comments and things like that
and just
um and i mean so many others josh and
joe did the music um it's just
man what an amazing my cup overflows
i do have i am in the tea kick tonight
as well i
what can i say lemon ginger turmeric
so good let's set that aside though it's
time to get going
so i am uh very very excited about
tonight
and um yeah grateful to be with all of
you i think it's gonna be really great
so um
let's see we are in this is part three
of our series titled epiphany
a radical invitation and the idea of the
season of epiphany in the church
calendar
is basically that it's it's just a time
to reflect on who christ was and
is who he reveals god to be and then
what our response
to that revealing is so you can see that
in many ways
epiphany is the perfect follow-up to the
christmas season of advent
because advent's all about waiting
receiving something from god that we do
not work for
or earn uh it's it's really a season of
contemplation
and grace but epiphany is different it's
it's the follow-up it's it's our
response
to the um as the church to the gift of
jesus himself so um with that in mind
the title of my message tonight
is the wonderful terrible grace
of god the wonderful terrible grace of
god
i think that will make more sense as we
go and our primary text is going to be
from jonah chapter 3 verses 1 through 10
and our very own nancy purdy
another amazing person who will be doing
our scripture reading tonight
so nancy can go ahead and take it away
my friend
then the word of the lord came to jonah
a second time
go to the great city of nineveh and
proclaim it
to it the message i give you jonah
obeyed the word of the lord and went to
nineveh
now nineveh was a very large city it
took three days to go through it
jonah began by going a day's journey
into the city
proclaiming forty more days and nineveh
will be overthrown
the ninevites will leave god a fast was
proclaimed
and all of them from the greatest to the
least
put on sackcloth when jonah's warning
reached the king of nineveh he rose from
his throne
took off his royal robes covered himself
with sackcloth
and sat down in the dust this is the
proclamation he
issued in nineveh by the decree
of the kings and his nobles do not let
people
or animals herds or flocks taste
anything do not let them eat or drink
but let people and animals be covered
with sackcloth
let everyone call urgently on god
let them give up their evil ways and
their violence
who knows god might yet relent
and with compassion turn from his fierce
anger
so that we will not perish when god
saw what they did and how they turned
from their evil ways
he relented and did not bring on them
the destruction he had threatened
jonah 1 3 1-10
thank you nancy beautiful um
so when you know when most people think
of the story of jonah
they they tend to think of jonah and the
what
the whale um it's the whale part of the
story that figures quite
prominently in many of our retellings of
this story
and um you know in sunday school
i think uh which is kind of like you
know children's church and things like
that
um we tend to focus a lot on the whale
because well you know it's interesting
and kind of strange and it lends itself
to do kind of a certain simplistic
moral telling of the story that kids can
kind of understand uh it's it's sort of
the low-hanging fruit so to speak
now having said that for those
unfamiliar with the story the passage
that nancy just read
it actually occurs about halfway through
the story like jonah's not it's not a
long book it's four chapters
and so that was the the first part
chapter three so it's like right there
halfway
um so let me give you some of the
background um just to kind of
refresh your your memory or bring you
into loop if you're not familiar with
jonah so
there is this a jewish prophet named
jonah
who the lord commands to go to nineveh
the city of nineveh
but jonah says um no and
he jumps on a ship for the town of
tarshish
uh which biblical commentators point out
is basically a town in precisely the
opposite direction of nineveh
so he jumps on the nearest ship and
heads in the opposite direction
uh however during his journey a storm
kicks up on the sea the sailors with
jonah
uh they begin to freak out they run up
to him they
ask didn't you say something about
running from god
and he's like yeah yeah um
i did i mentioned mentioned that's
unfortunate you remember that
so jonah basically says he's very
compassionate he's like look throwing me
overboard
is my fault and they protest
because they're like oh my gosh your
blood will be on our hands we can do
this but
eventually the storm's so bad they do um
the storm it begins to kind of ease but
then a whale once they throw him
overboard but then a whale from the deep
swallows jonah up and he proceeds to sit
in the belly of that great beast
for three days and three nights and as
the story goes he prays to god
and towards the end of that time and he
says
okay i relent i i will obey and then the
whale
vomits him up onto dry land and then
that brings us up to chapter three where
god says okay jonah
go um so so you can see how we might
teach this
to to you know children um when god
tells us to do
something the moral of the story goes we
must obey god we must not
run away from the will of god we need to
obey
and i think that's a great truth from
the the book of jonah
um but i i do think there's more going
on in in the text and then that can be a
little bit
uh simplistic um so but then even as
adults honestly we kind of
it's easy to miss it because um
we still end up circling kind of our own
telling of the story
around the whale the whale part of the
story
because we're endlessly debating the
question of whether or not it's
really possible for someone to be
swallowed by a whale and survive
so you know group a of christians they
say like well of course
of course it is because the bible says
it
and so that settles it and then group b
is like well
just that seems a little far-fetched to
me and you know
does christianity kind of have to come
to grips with
science if it's ever going to be a
respectable religion in the modern world
and there's maybe
mythology in the bible you know it's all
around it goes and so around the two
sides go
um but meanwhile what has been lost
to us uh here's what has been lost to us
the book of jonah is not
about the whale
focusing on the whale is a massive
adventure in missing the point i mean
we'd be
better off almost doing the sunday
school version of at least talking about
the
the call to go and obedience and things
like that um
but i just like man we really miss it on
the book of jonah all right so what is
the book
of jonah what's it really about what's
the heart of it
um so to understand that we first need
to understand some background we need to
understand where the city of nineveh
uh was found so nineveh was the capital
of assyria
and the assyrian empire was a nation of
bloodshed and terror and they were also
one of the most powerful empires of the
ancient world
and so in the year 732 bc
uh so about 700 years or so before
christ they
they basically sieged the the israelite
um
capital at that time it was samaria and
then they
conquered the northern half of the
jewish
people known as as kind of collectively
as israel you kind of had judah down
south and then
israel up north uh and and let me tell
you when the assyrians conquered anyone
like they
they weren't polite about it uh and we
don't know
the exact that israel face they
don't the bible doesn't give us like
tons of details
um but we can kind of guess and and we
know this um
some of it's a lot of it i should say is
from archaeology from inscriptions
carvings from around that time
concerning the practices of
assyria here's an image the assyrians
themselves created
of the tortures they put people through
conquered peoples
um i think scott's gonna go ahead and
put that up so it's it's basically you
can see
kind of there at the top it's kind of
someone maybe uh
plucking out a beard um and that's about
the best of it someone else is getting
their tongue
torn out um it was i mean it's it's not
not good
uh further archaeological evidence can
be seen from an inscription this is from
a temple
in the assyrian city of nimrod that
recounts they basically recounted the
fate of some leaders from
um the city uh this was another city
they conquered
i think it was called sir they said that
sir rebelled against the empire
and so assyria came and put
them to death so um and what i want you
to notice is this is actually
um this is a syria who put these
exploits in their own temple so we got
this inscription
from the assyrians themselves i mean
they're basically bragging so
this is he says this i king asher
benepal
the the assyrian king i built a pillar
at the city gate
and i flayed all the chief men who had
revolted and i
covered the pillar with their skins some
i walled up inside the pillar some
i impaled upon the pillar on stakes
ah these these were brutal brutal people
uh and here's this is actually a passage
from the the bible this is the prophetic
book of nahum
chapter 3 and there's a
a lot of chapters have kind of a little
title over the top and this is titled
woe to nineveh because the book of jonah
isn't the only
mention of them in the bible so this is
nahum chapter 3
woe to the city of blood full of lies
full of plunder never without victims
the crack of whips the clatter of wheels
galloping horses and jolting chariots
charging cavalry flashing swords and
glittering spears
many casualties piles of dead bodies
without number
people stumbling over corpses
so so this is what the book of jonah is
about
and and it's why when god shows up and
says to jonah i want you to go to
nineveh and preach against it
jonah says no
now you might think we're preaching
against it that's you should enjoy that
but no because
where there is preaching there is
warning
and where there is warning there is the
possibility
of repentance of of change
of transformation and jonah doesn't want
those
possibilities for assyria you know what
jonah wants
revenge he wants death and
judgment because that's what they
deserved
he wants god to wipe them out
here's the ending of the story from the
very end of chapter three and then we go
into chapter
four of the book of jonah so this is the
last verse that um
that nancy read when god saw what they
did
and how they turned from their evil ways
right because they repented this is what
happened
uh he relented and did not bring on them
the destruction he
had threatened then we go into chapter
four this is the very next verse chapter
four verse one
but to jonah this seemed
very wrong and he became
angry and he prayed to the lord
isn't this what i said lord when i was
still at home
that is what i tried to forestall by
fleeing
to tarshish i knew i knew
that you are listen this language i knew
that you are a
gracious and compassionate
god slow to anger and abounding in love
a god
who relents from sending calamity
now lord take away my life it is better
for me to die
than to live verse 4 but the lord
replied
is it right for you to be angry
is it right for you to be angry and then
skipping down to verse 11 god continues
and should i not have concern
for the great city of nineveh in which
there are more than a hundred and twenty
thousand people who cannot tell their
right hand
from their left and also many animals
and that's literally how the book ends
that's it with this hanging question
should i not have concern
for them jonah
because of course the book of jonah is
not simply about some guy who lived a
while back
and it's certainly not primarily about a
whale
instead it is about us in god
in our response to those we call enemy
to those we call oppressor to those who
have mistreated
and betrayed us
oh the wonderful grace of god wonderful
when it is shown to those
we love oh the terrible
grace of god terrible when it is shown
to those we hate
you know make no mistake about it um
this is the wisdom
and the scandal of the book of jonah
and honestly it is to the jewish
people's credit that they
included this book in their holy
scriptures
it's i mean it's completely remarkable
uh that this made it in
it really is the wisdom in the scandal
of the book of jonah
and it's it's a picture of the wisdom in
the scandal
of the christian faith as well and you
say wow what do you mean christian faith
how do we go from book of jonah to like
new testament christianity um i mean
it's the cross
i i'm thinking of the cross of jesus
christ
let me unpack this so um here's the
thing
in a concrete moment or season of
history
you can kind of zoom in and you can
see um like oh look at that
uh we have a pretty dang clear
oppressor and someone oppressed we have
the righteous
and the wicked right just think of jonah
with israel assyria the empire
conquering another i mean it's awful
right so it's you zoom in enough and
there you have it
oppressor oppressed um but here's the
thing
if you zoom out enough if you
allow enough time to pass in a person or
a tribe's life
the categories suddenly
what happens they they become rather
blurry
and you realize that as flaming rutledge
says
the line of good and evil cuts right
through the heart of every human being
that this is really the scandal that
jonah
did not understand and and it's the
wisdom and the scandal
of the cross because to the question
uh who crucified the innocent son of god
the answer is of course not oh those
people
those bad people over there what's the
what's the answer everyone
and and the gospels make this very clear
it's the gentile roman politicians
it's the jewish religious leaders
and it's the nameless faceless mob
representing of course who
all of us and and in the story if you've
ever heard the gospels around the
crucifixion of jesus
you'll remember the the point where the
the mob
is shouting out crucify him crucify him
right and and this was paul's the
apostle paul's insight in romans chapter
verse 10 when he's naming
what the cross of jesus reveals
what did it show this is what paul says
romans chapter 3 verse 10
there is no one righteous
not even one but what is righteous that
means
righteousness is about relationship
there's no one right right with
themselves
right with god right with other people
no one righteous not even one
and you might say this is the bad news
of the cross i mean who put jesus on the
cross
i did we did like
those people and my people those tribes
and my tribe the same
evil in them is in who
in me the same shadow side in them
is in me as paul reiterates later in
romans chapter 11 verse 32
he says that the cross of jesus shows
that god has
bound everyone over to
disobedience and you might be thinking
to yourself like well
this is kind of offensive because i'm a
good person
be honest now are you i mean i'm sure
you have beautiful moments
uh like i'm not someone who says you
know humans are only
terrible i'm sure there are times where
you really are like loving and good
but isn't that darkness in you too
isn't that rage that envy
that greed that capacity for hate
and violence even if you don't let it
out
like you do all you can to kind of keep
it suppressed because you're you know
christian
but isn't that lurking
in you too it's lurking in me
so so then you might say well okay i may
not be perfect but my tribe
my people we are the good people
our intentions are pure we
see clearly and we act
righteously it is the rest of the world
those other tribes those other religions
those
other cultures those other political
parties they they
have the problem
really uh so i'm sorry but i'm with paul
and jesus on this one
um god has bound everyone over to
disobedience
it's in all of us the line of good and
evil cuts right through the heart of all
of us
that's the bad news but it doesn't end
there
back to romans 11 32 paul says for god
has bound everyone over to disobedience
so that he may have mercy on
them all
so that he may have mercy on them
all you see the cross of jesus
just like the book of jonah is terrible
and beautiful terrible
because it cuts right through
all of our bs this is why i'm a
christian by the way like
because i just it just it just exposes
me and my soul
i mean that's what the cross does right
it just cuts right through all of our bs
and our lies and our self-aggrandizement
and our presumption of us and
our tribe's innocence and it says
no stop with the charade
you are guilty that's why it's
terrible so to speak but it's beautiful
it's beautiful because it is also
god in christ saying i remember jonah's
words
i am gracious and compassionate
slow to anger abounding in love
abounding in forgiveness abounding in
healing and reconciliation
and i have chosen to have mercy on
everyone this is god's
message i am saving every one that's the
invitation is to
everyone not not just your
church or your little tribe or
your family or your kind of people
i am transforming the world god says
through suffering
love that was god's word to jonah that
was god's word to
all of us in the cross it's the same
word and that's why they call it gospel
which means
good news it's good news
it's good news for everyone for all
people so i was reflecting this week
on you know what what does this mean for
us in other words how how do we live
differently um tomorrow
you know in light of of these ideas
uh and it brought to mind a passage this
is also from
paul and it's second corinthians chapter
5 verse 18
and 19. and i see it very deeply tied to
the themes of the book of jonah
to the themes the passages we just read
in romans
and into the cross so second corinthians
5 verses 18 19 paul says this
all this is from god who reconciled
us to himself through christ again
that's right cross and resurrection
you reconciled us to himself through
christ and then what do you do
and he gave us the ministry
of what of reconciliation can you see it
god reconciles us to himself but doesn't
just stop there
it's not just oh good well i'm saved
praise the lord hallelujah
what is why he he reconciles us and then
he
commissions us he gives us the ministry
of reconciliation verse 19 clarifies a
little bit
that god was reconciling the world to
himself in christ
not counting people's sins against
them and he has committed to us
the message the ministry
of reconciliation what does
reconciliation in this relational sense
mean reconciliation means
healed restored right
relationship you see this is this is
really the great problem
of our world we are fractured
broken disjointed
in our relationship to god to ourselves
and to other people
uh and i'll leave the connection to god
in ourselves for other sermons
um let's talk about our relationship
with others can anyone
look at our world the last few months
and earth heck the last few years
and doubt that we have broken
relationships
all around us we are a mess
and so this this begs the question what
is
our call what is your
call well assuming that you
follow jesus then you have a double
mission do you know you have a double
mission in your life
like you don't just have one thing you
do you have always two things see
one mission is whatever you do each day
and it's important that whatever you do
you do as well as you can right whether
you are a mother or a computer
programmer
a teacher a grandparent a realtor
an event coordinator i don't know all
sorts of things people do
right that's one mission um but don't be
confused
you have a second mission
you have an agenda with everyone you
interact with and here is your agenda
reconciliation
everywhere you look there is brokenness
and strife
and anger and reactionary living
right this is our mission at the table
to shift a generation
from reactionary
right from a reactionary to visionary to
the person and work of jesus why because
everywhere we look there is brokenness
strife anger and reactionary living
so and so is hacked off at so and so
this
tribe is against that tribe
but as a citizen of the kingdom of god
as a follower of christ
you go into the world you are present
and you are constantly asking yourself
and god
lord how how can i
be an agent of reconciliation
here that's your prayer that's the
question
how can i be an agent of reconciliation
here
what would it look like for me to sow
seeds of love forgiveness
and peace in this
moment and i'll be
really honest um this is a high calling
and it is one i struggle with mightily
but sometimes maybe
five percent of the time i get it
right and so at the i run a great risk
tonight of tooting my own horn
hopefully you all know me well enough by
now to know i am completely willing to
share my failures
um i do that quite a bit in my sermons
tonight let me share
one success i had um i really
debated whether to share this so be
gentle
especially the first part of this text
could sound very self-congratulatory
so a few months ago i received a text
from
a co-worker so i worked from the month
of february of this past year through
like early october um at a marketing
agency in dallas
as a part-time project manager that was
kind of my background when i worked in
the corporate world was project
management
uh and so i kind of went back into that
um skills to pay the bills you know
and so um so i was doing that and there
was
um it was a great experience it was good
to be kind of out of the church world
and and back in with um just you know
normal folks it was great
um and i worked with some really lovely
people um but i did i had a connection a
friendship with someone
and you know we got off to a little bit
of a rocky start when she she came on
just a little bit after me
and um she had some she was she's a very
straightforward person and she had some
kind of criticisms
basically of how i was kind of running
things um
and uh and we we had to work them
through
and it never got ugly or anything but it
was you know we had to work it through
and i did my best
with it why because i knew i was there
with a double mission
they also knew i was a pastor part-time
and a christian you know i mean like it
was i wasn't hiding anything
and i just and honestly even apart from
that like i really wanted to
i wanted to live this stuff you know
like i i wanted to um make an
impact and in a positive way and so um
the day after my time at that company um
came today it was supposed to be only
six months kind of where i was a
contractor and then
it went a little longer because of covid
but eventually that came to a close
and so i get home that evening and i
received
this text from her
her name was andrea she said hey brett i
just want to say thank you
so much for all your amazing work and
your work ethic you're seriously a great
project manager
by the way she's been very kind i am a
very mediocre project manager
all right said your attitude your energy
is so pure and amazing and this is the
part she said it was absolutely awesome
to have you as a co-worker
and to work with you thanks for always
being so kind to me
thanks for always being so kind to me
wishing you and your family the best
in that line thanks for always being so
kind to me
that got me i mean i just sat there on
our little bench in my living room i
just started like
quietly it wasn't boohooing but you know
the tears rolled down my face and here's
why
because that was my prayer every morning
that i walked through those office
stores
i wanted to be an agent of kindness
of goodness of reconciliation
because that's what it means to be a
christian and again lord knows i fail at
that
way too often but at least this one time
i got it right
and so church ah this is our mission
let's not be like jonah offended at the
wonderful terrible grace of god
let's be like christ agents
ambassadors of the kingdom of god
bringing
love and kindness forgiveness and
reconciliation everywhere we go
embodying living and extending
the wonderful grace of god to all
people let me pray for you lord jesus
i i ask
god for the grace over
all of us to be able to live this
out god it is a high high calling
so i asked first off god that this truth
of
of the love and grace that you've shown
us the the reconciliation the the way
you
extended your arms on that cross and
communicated how far you're willing to
go to
to love us to forgive us to be healed
and reconciled with
us god thank you for that and maybe
you're listening to my words right now
and you've never it's never really sunk
in
quite the depths to which god went to
restore a relationship with you
and i want you to know that he did that
for you
but it doesn't end there god you've now
called us to be agents to be
ambassadors of your kingdom god to be
to have an agenda an agenda of love and
reconciliation everywhere we go
and so god would you do that work in us
would that
truth seep into our bones and may we go
wherever we go whether it's an
interaction with our family tonight
or going into work tomorrow
grocery shopping the the interaction
with the waiter the waitress
the bank teller got whatever it looks
like that may we
be agents of peace
of kindness of courage
of justice of reconciliation
but that's our prayer in the powerful
life-changing name of jesus i pray
amen
blessed are the ones who do not bury
all the broken pieces of their
heart
blessed are the tears
pouring like a sky of falling
stars
blessed are the wounded ones
brave enough to show the lord their
scars
blessed are the hurts that are not
hidden
open to the healing touch of
god the kingdom
is yours
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this
is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your
eyes on him
[Music]
blessed are the ones who walk in
kindness
even in the face of great abuse
[Music]
and blessed are the deeds
blessed are the ones who fight for
justice
[Music]
the last lost
the kingdom is yours
[Music]
hold on a little more this
is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this
is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
blessed are the poor in spirit
blessed are the pure in heart
[Music]
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this
is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him the kingdom is
hold on a little more this
is
keep your eyes on him
[Music]
this is not
is
amen thank you so much for joining us
tonight
i hope that the service blessed you and
reminded you that you're not alone
and it gave you some things to really
take into this week with you
as we close out i just wanted to mention
a couple things
first of all even though we are
continuing to be a church online we are
still a church we are still a community
we are still real people and we want to
be there for you
whether it's prayer a listening ear
or to be there for you in other tangible
ways
you can reach out to us marissa's gonna
post a link
below ways that you can get in contact
with us we would love to hear from you
and be able to be there for you second
if you resonate with the values and the
vision
and the things we're doing here at the
table we would so appreciate
a financial donation just to ensure that
our community keeps going
and thriving especially in the midst of
cobit it's been tough
so if you are able you can give on our
website
at www.thetabletx.org
and i believe marissa's also going to
post a link for that marissa thank you
for all of that tonight the ways that
you're posting and keeping us connected
here on the live stream we really really
appreciate you
so as you go into your week let me send
you out with this benediction
you are a child of god this is true
on your best days and it's true on your
worst days
you were wonderfully and lovingly made
there is
only one you nothing about you is a
mistake
and this world needs you being fully
yourself
authentic and free so as you go into the
week ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you
are worthy and you are accepted just as
you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend
these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love
to everyone you come in contact with i
hope you have a great week
and i hope to see you back here next
sunday bye
you